♪ ♪ ♪
♪ Jojo was a man
who thought he was a loner ♪
♪ But he knew it couldn't last ♪
- Peter Jackson,s s s avez
travaillé pendant quatre ans
sur le documentaire "Get Back".
En fait, c'est l'histoire
de la production de l'album
"Let It t t t t vous avez eu
accès à 57 heures de bande
vidéo. C'est un rêve pour
les fans, mais pour vous aussi,
j'imagine que c'était
ndndndnd rêve.
♪ ♪
Vous avez aussi joué au
journaliste, Peter Jackson,
parce qu'on le sait,
la production de "Let It Be"
a longtemps eu mauvaise presse.
Vous avez voulu montrer
une autre image.
♪ No, no ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ One, two, three... ♪
Notre mémoire peut nous
jouer de mauvais tours,
alors comment Paul McCartney
et Ringo Starr ont réagi
après avoir vu votre film?
- "Harrison is accused
assaulting a photographer
last May as he and Beatle Ringo
Starr left a nightclub."
♪ ♪ ♪
Hey!
- Votre documentaire est
d'une durée de 6 heures,
mais vous avez travaillé avec
57 h-c-c-c-c-c-c-c-c-c-ce qu'un
jour, on pourrait avoir droit
à un documentaire de votre part
de, je ne sais pas, moi,
20 heures?
- Hello! Welcome to the first
ofkikikikikikikikikikiking
of "The Hobbit"...
- Vous avez accompli de grands
rêves en réalisant "Le Seigneur
des anneaux", maintenant
eaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaeatles.
À quoi rêvez-vous maintenant,
Peter Jackson?
Peter Jac
plaisir de vous parler, merci.
♪ Get back Jo! ♪
♪ ♪ ♪